[Musique]
évidemment un festival électro s'adresse
d'abord à ceux qui aiment l'électro mais
du fait de notre programmation
pluridisciplinaire on a aussi l'espoir
de toucher
des publics qui ne viendraient pas
spontanément l'électro
aujourd'hui est une musique
extrêmement intéressante par toutes les
facettes qu'elle développe et par la
complexité des sons qu'elle proposait en
même temps la beauté qui s'exprime
nous aurons plusieurs artistes nous
aurons arnaud rebotini je vous en
parlais nous aurons six minagri gorioux
thierry balasse
labié triche
nous organisons un jury chaque année
chargée d'auditionner les
candidatures
d'un certain nombre de jeunes musiciens
auxquels nous proposons de jouer en live
en direct devant le public
[Musique]
lors d'une des soirées du festival